- [Reporter] The morning of October 9th,
fragments of a Hamas missile
land less than a mile outside
of Ben Gurion Airport,
Israel's main international airport.
(passengers shouting)
On the ground, passengers ran for cover.
In the skies above,
A Ryanair flight on
approach diverted away.
And yet, in a matter of minutes,
aircraft resumed taking off
and landing at the airport,
while the war continued.
Despite it being less than 40 miles
from the front lines of
Israel's war with Gaza,
Ben Gurion airport has remained open
throughout the conflict.
And while civil air spaces
above war zones, like Ukraine,
often remain closed from
the moment war breaks out,
Israel's civil airspace has continued
to receive commercial traffic.
- I think the key question
here that everyone's asking is
why haven't the Israelis
closed their airspace?
And I think the answer is
countries are always going to err
on the side of keeping it open.
- [Reporter] So how does
Israel keep an airport open
in a warzone?
And what are the risks to
aircraft in the airspace?
Keeping airspace open can
provide a vital corridor
for Israel to allow people
to leave, soldiers to return,
and goods and supplies to
continue entering the country
during the conflict.
One of the steps the country has taken
to try and protect those aircraft
is to change the route they're
approaching Ben Gurion from.
- The main mitigation
measure that we've taken
is completely separating the routes
from the area of the conflict.
The routes, basically,
in and out of Israel
are much northern than they are usually,
going 10 miles south of Haifa.
- [Reporter] According to
Israel's Civil Aviation Authority,
the country's civil and
military air traffic controllers
also work very closely together
and often sit in the same buildings
and look at the same aerial picture.
(missile fires)
And that allows them to coordinate
on trying to ensure that missiles
from the country's Iron Dome system
don't impact civilian aircraft
when they're intercepting Hamas missile.
- It still leaves plenty of flexibility
for the defense systems
to plan their engagement,
to plan their interception of a rocket.
- [Reporter] On the ground,
while Ben Gurion in
airport can normally have
over 10 aircraft waiting at its gates...
- We've limited the number of aircraft
that are loaded with
passengers and with fuel,
so you would see maximum
six, normally four.
- [Reporter] And when the
aircraft are ready to depart,
takeoff is as swift as possible,
with no queuing on the runway.
Israel's Civil Aviation Authority
says that part of the reason
it's able to keep its airspace open
is because it has
remained open previously,
through years of Hamas missile attacks.
- So no one is doing anything new.
Civil Aviation doesn't
like doing new stuff,
not in general, and
specifically not in conflict.
- [Reporter] And that's why the country
issued a notice to airlines,
saying its airspace would remain open
but that airlines should use caution,
a notice the FAA and EASA,
its European equivalent,
have also sent out.
Yet, despite this, the vast
bulk of international carriers
have paused flying to Tel Aviv.
While many airlines
stopped flying to Tel Aviv
the day Hamas launched
its surprise attack,
others continued to to
fly for a few days more.
A British Airways flight
actually turned back
moments before landing,
as air raid sirens were sounding
in the area surrounding the airport.
- [Pilot] British Airways
has issued a statement,
saying it's suspended
all flights to Tel Aviv
until further notice.
- Some Arnos, even though
their insurance allows
these operations, they don't want it.
Again, understandable.
- [Reporter] Even though
the airspace remains open,
airlines will have many
questions to consider
if they operate flights into the region.
- How frequent is the
rocket fire from Gaza?
How deep into Israel are
Rockets being launched?
Where are those Iron Dome
intercepts taking place?
- [Narrator] Matt Borie is
Chief Intelligence Officer
and one of the co-founders
of Osprey Flight Solutions,
an aviation risk management company
that advises the likes of America's TSA.
His job is to evaluate some
of the worst-case scenarios,
and he thinks that Israel's airspace
should be more restricted.
- The area where the
conflict is affecting,
which includes Northern
Israel, Haifa, Tel Aviv,
should be paused until the trajectory
of this conflict becomes more clear.
- [Reporter] Matt cautioned that,
even though aircraft were being rerouted
to approach over Haifa,
there had still been recent
surface-to-air missile,
or SAM, activity in the region.
- The IDF has confirmed they employed
a conventional SAM system to
shoot down a rocket launch
from Gaza, near Haifa.
- [Reporter] Footage of
the impact later appeared
on social media.
- Why this is a concern
is because now we're
creating the conditions
for a shoot-down.
Civil aviation flying in between areas
where conflict activity is happening.
- [Reporter] Israel says
that when a missile is fired,
its air traffic controllers
can have over a minute and a half
to maneuver aircraft out of the area,
and in that time, aircraft
can cover around 10 miles.
While neither Hamas nor Israel
is likely to intentionally
target civilian aircraft,
according to Matt, there's still a risk
that an aircraft could be shot down
if it's misidentified as
a missile or other threat,
which is exactly what happened
when Malaysia Airlines Flight 17
was shot down over eastern
Ukraine by pro-Russia militia.
- Weather caused this aircraft
to deviate from its flight path,
which led to the rebel group
to interpret it as not a civilian airliner
because it wasn't flying on
the civilian airliner routes,
so Osprey has already told its clients
that we assess the potential
for miscalculation or misidentification
in Israeli airspace to be
likely in the near term
under the current scenario.
- [Reporter] Israel denies
that misidentification
is a major risk factor in its airspace.
- There are technical limitations
on some of the systems that, again,
there is no possibility
that an interceptor
could target a civilian aircraft.
If anyone has a minimal
knowledge in aviation,
a screen showing a drone
and a civilian aircraft
and a fighter jet looks
very, very different.
And the MA-17 and other
tragic accidents that happened
have a very, very different background,
and none of it is
relevant in this conflict.
- [Reporter] While the situation in Israel
is already complex, the
addition of outside forces,
like Syria and Hezbollah,
who have already engaged
in limited artillery
exchanges with Israel,
could complicate things further.
- Do you trust Hezbollah
will not make a mistake
on firing on a target
over northern Israel?
- [Reporter] Israel, however,
says that it is monitoring
risks from all sides.
- We're monitoring very, very closely
and looking at the risk very carefully,
monitoring the situation in Lebanon,
monitoring the situation in Syria.
I can assure you that,
if we see many rockets
launched towards Ben Gurion,
we will freeze traffic in Ben Gurion,
and traffic will go to Eilat Ramon.
- [Reporter] As the situation in the skies
above Israel evolves, its
aviation authority maintains
that it will remain
accountable, whatever happens
- We monitor the situation closely.
We listen to intel.
We see ourselves as accountable.
And we look at this role
very, very seriously.
(tense music)